la reina isabel visitó francia 13 veces
más que cualquier otro país de europa
desde jaén hasta el actual emanuel
manjón la reina no solo fue testigo de
momentos clave de la historia de francia
sino que participó en ellos su última
visita de estado a francia fue en 2014
cuando participó en las conmemoraciones
del desembarco del día de junto a
françois hollande y barack obama y todas
las miradas estaban puestas en ella como
única jefa de estado que participó
realmente en la segunda guerra mundial
durante su visita la monarca recibió el
cariño de los franceses un sentimiento
que según ella era mutuo
[Aplausos]
recuerdo el placer que tuve cuando
descubrí este hermoso país por primera
vez y cultive a su vez un gran afecto
por el pueblo francés
fawcett fue en
1948 cuando la entonces princesa realizó
su primer viaje en solitario al
extranjero y eligió francia no tardó en
encantar a la nación
aficionada a la francofonía fue la
primera vez que impresionó con un
francés fluido que aprendió de niña
el rango
y fue educada para ver a francia como el
canal de la mancha para cruzar
literalmente el canal pero también para
verlo como el canal para que reino unido
se relacionará con el resto de europa
en 1960 recibió a jack de gol como héroe
de la segunda guerra mundial y dado su
papel en la contienda bélica sentía un
gran respeto por el primer el líder de
la quinta república lo siguiente en
visitarla fue el georges pompidou luego
valéry giscard d'estaing cuyo saludo
real la hizo sonreír y fue obsequiado
con un cachorro de la perrera de la
reina las relaciones entre las dos
naciones se intensificaron cuando la
monarca inauguró el túnel del canal de
la mancha con el presidente me pega que
pasó a convertirse en un símbolo de los
vínculos francos británicos
y cruzar el canal en un coche tan cómodo
como el suyo sra
los presidentes jacques chirac y nicolas
sarkozy también fueron testigos del
afecto que la reina sentía por francia y
más recientemente emanuel manjón a quien
recibió en 2019 con motivo del 75
aniversario del día-d en portsmouth a lo
largo de su vida no sólo fue a francia
para visitas oficiales sino también para
ver a sus amadas carreras de caballos en
repetidas ocasiones por ello era lógico
que el presidente mayor le regalara un
caballo con motivo del jubileo de
platino este mes de junio